[BREATHES DEEP] Aaaaaah!
Don’t you just love that new car smell?
Smells like power and freedom!
Actually, it smells more like petroleum-based
solvents evaporating off vinyl and plastic.
Wow, buzzkill.
Let’s see if you still like that smell when
you find out what it's really costing you...
I’m locking the windows.
[SOUND OF WINDOWS ROLLING UP]
[MUSIC]
Since the auto boom of the 1950's, cars have
become an integral part of American society.
Car companies spent 14.2 BILLION dollars in
advertising alone in 2014 and that number
is only rising.
They convince us that once we’re behind
the wheel, our families will love us more,
our neighbors will envy us, and our freedom
to go anywhere is secure.
Unfortunately, they’re more likely to take
away your freedom and security.
New cars are a financial triple threat.
We borrow money at interest, to buy an asset
that we have to PAY to maintain and...here’s
the big kicker...that drastically depreciates
in value.
Wait… what IS depreciation, anyway?
Hey Julia, would you like to buy some ice
cream?
Uh, sure, I guess--
That’ll be four dollars.
I wouldn’t pay a nickel for that!
But I paid four dollars for it twenty minutes
ago!
That’s depreciation.
Go wash your hands.
Cars retain their value about as well as ice
cream on a hot day.
A new car will depreciate 63% in the first
five years.
10% of that the MOMENT you drive it off the
lot!
Calling cars a “bad investment” is like
calling a honey badger a bad heart surgeon.
What?
I mean they’re not an investment at all!
Exactly.
I mean, can you think of anything else you’d
spend that much money on that loses value
that quickly?
Oh, I don’t know.
How about a garage full of beanie babies?
[HORROR MOVIE MUSIC]
Heh, I told you the 90’s are comin’ back.
Sure, hon.
And don't think you can get out of this by
leasing either!
Leasing companies set their prices so that
you pay for the depreciation of their vehicle,
and when it’s over they still have an asset
they can re-sell.
So let’s set a few simple ground rules that
will put you in the driver’s seat instead
of being taken for a ride:
Number One.
Buy a car that’s 5 years old.
Right away, you’re skipping the majority
of its depreciation.
Number Two.
Save up to buy a car in cash.
Paying interest on something that loses value
is like gaining weight from exercising.
All pain.
No gain.
Number Three.
If you can't comfortably afford to save an
amount equal to your car payment, you can't
afford it.
So if you're not saving $300 a month, you
shouldn’t take on a $300 car payment.
So how much money is actually at stake?
I think it’s time to....
RUN THE NUMBERS!
Let’s say I buy a new car for $20,000.
I put $4,000 down, and I finance the rest
over 60 months at 4.25%.
My monthly payment will be--
$295.42!
That sounds pretty normal.
But check this out.
What if you bought that same car, but a 5
year old model, which costs you 63% less -- or
$7,400.
Put your same $4,000 down, and with the same
loan arrangement, you’re looking at a payment
of just $62.78/mo.
That’s a monthly saving of--
$232.65!
I could get a massage every other week with
that!
You could.
Or, you could take those monthly savings and
put them into a growing asset, like a home
or a mutual fund.
And if you continued to do that EVERY time
you paid off the car, even at a very conservative
7% per year return, in 35 years you’d have
over...
$421,459!
Really?
Wow.
Now...is that enough to retire on?
Probably not.
But that’s just one thing you can start
doing now to prepare for your future.
There are many, many more.
Y’know, as much I like that new car smell,
I don’t think I’d spend half a mil on it.
Let's try this instead.
Ooh, what’s that?
EARLY RETIREMENT, BABY! Bam!
And that’s our two cents!
[MUSIC]